the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's talk about the important
important think thoughts for the week
portent concepts what do you have energy
method I'm going to say this work this
work energy theorem so from that we call
these turn out to be our potential
energies and this - the work done by the
conservative forces we call B 1 V 2
minus V 1 that's the change in the
potential energy of the system so that's
the work energy theorem that's an
important one for the week what else
yeah we did some bunch a several example
problems particularly emphasizing what
yeah or points that look like they're
moving but you can use consideration I'm
calling them instantaneous centers of
rotation and things like around right so
summation of the torques with respect to
points sometimes moving to find this is
with respect to ICRS instantaneous
centers of rotation and also moving
points definitely did some of that how
about a third
well last year
I'd say one more thing that we've got
started on is expressions you know a
half eye half a mega dot h plus i have
one half MV dot v dot v you know those
kind of terms for this and force
potential energy if it's purely
mechanical devices we have two kinds of
potential energy that we'll be dealing
with than they are associated with
springs and gravity so we have that's
the two that we'll deal with are there
others what's an example of a different
kind of potential energy that you might
run into magnetic fields yeah you do
work pulling something out of a magnetic
field what else electric fields sure but
they do have their complications so
that's that's pretty good for the week
now what we're going to talk about this
problem it'll give him a chance to shoot
it this is a good diagram of it this is
you guys had a you had a homework
problem that instead of a uniform rod
you had a a concentrated mass on the end
of a massless rod right so this is
almost identical to that but we didn't
know we now have actual mass distributed
mass in the stick I've got a little demo
here which will work works after a
fashion put a little tension on these
Springs so now I've got my cart on a
spring the damping's natural in the
system comes from the wheels and
everything else I'm gonna get this kind
of close to the edge so it'll work this
thing has two natural frequencies
actually they're kind of hard to isolate
them there's one you know can't do it in
one natural mode the thing swings
forward and moves forward together and
then the other natural mode this will go
after
that way while the other ones go in
front weren't so let's see if hanging
that's higher frequency
there's the that's the motion of what's
called the second mode opposite and the
first mode is lower for this lower
frequency than that
it's hard to get a perfect start to it
so this is the kind of motion we're
talking about and we're going to have
you help me solve we want to pay obtain
equations of motion for this system and
let's quickly run through the exercise
if you can do this intuitively first
it's so simple plus you've already done
it how many independent coordinates does
it take to do it - and how many rigid
bodies are there in this problem how
many rigid bodies in the problem every -
right there's a block moves back and
forth and there's this rod that swings
so the number of degrees of freedom
D is six times the number of bodies and
the number bodies minus the number of
constraints so this is six times two
minus the constraint so we've got 12
minus C and you know the answers
what do you answer how many how many
independent coordinates are completely
describe this motion just a two so you
know the answers to that means you got
to come up with ten a list of ten of
these things so let's see if you can
write down quickly your own list how
would you how would you eliminate
through coming up with constraints write
down the ten constraints and I recommend
you do it by taking one body at a time
so constraints on mass one the first
block what do you get
okay so that says little motion in the Y
direction because it's on the run
rollers it's fixed that way so no no no
motion and why what else no motion and
city work telling it can't come in and
out of the board
okay any other translational constraints
on that one so no Y or Z translation and
so that gives us two constraints there
what else on that body
no rotations in what direction in X Y or
Z I think it only translates so no X Y Z
rotations that's three that's total five
and we have but we have one left
it's got to be able to move in the X
right and how about em - what are the
constraints on this second one so one at
a time
- so Omega which no rotations in about
which axes so you're saying this no
rotations of this about the X of can't
roll over about the why it can't turn
the guy and about the Z what about it
how about we're doing this one so it's
no spinning at bat let's do it in its
body coordinates x1 no spinning about x1
no spinning about y1 but can it rotate
around z1 okay so for the second mass we
have no x1 y1 rotations that's - and
what about translations on the second
body
no translations X Y & Z so Z pretty
obvious we're not letting it do this but
why why can you argue there's no
translation in X&Y
it's just strictly rotation okay so
you're saying translation is strictly
described as parallel motion of all
points on it right but where where is it
constrained in X&Y it's pinned to the
curve and if you fix X which you're
allowed to do I mean a test you're
allowed to do you've a set this as an
independent coordinate if you fix it
this point is fixed and you've
constrained it in x and y right and if
any point in the object is constrained
in x and y then all points are
constrained in x and y pure translation
but so we have in this one no x y and z
translations so that's three you add
them up you get ten okay good now the
next thing i want you to do another key
step in doing this problems like this is
our free body diagrams and how many do
you need as many as you have rigid
bodies you need one for every rigid body
so we've got two rigid bodies draw for
me your free body diagram for the cart
and for the rod
okay let's what group wants to volunteer
here tell me what we've what I ought to
do
how about you guys in the back you're
quiet today so let's talk let's just
pick this first one okay the X dot I'll
see if me and pulling here with a rod
okay so you're saying we've got a force
a vector force like that some F right
okay
how how about a little help on this
anybody have a different result here for
this one
so you'd have two pieces here so it
won't what direction you draw them I
guess which coordinate system we've got
we need two coordinate systems to define
this problem so we got our I've got a
inertial frame here and that gives me my
X capital X motion for this guy but we
need because if we want to be able to
use moments of inertia and things like
that we need a coordinate system
attached to this rigid body right so
I've called it little x1 y1 it moves
with body okay so in years or so years
or you've picked your two reaction
forces aligned with these two or aligned
in this system okay you've done it this
way the year coming up with a pair of
forces that look they have a piece like
this and a piece like that oh but the
wheels okay you came up with individual
ones here yeah okay that Cauley I'll
call that n1 and n2 and that's probably
an improvement cuz it that's what keeps
it from rolling over right okay that's
true and what else so you got a reaction
force here like that that's the way I
can we improve on that
yeah but I understood that the intention
here was it was drawn collinear with the
axis of the thing right and that
suggested just that one part you could
break that into a horizontal in the
master frame yeah but anybody have
something different about that another
way to do this is that you do you agree
with this is that is this correct
right you treat it like a string is it a
string can it can it can that shaft
transmit shear forces hmm if I grab this
thing and go left and right on it it's
putting forces in that direction
perpendicular to this so is it
conceivable that there are forces on
this axle caused by that that are in
that direction as well as that direction
what do you think and you I can't make
an argument for sure that would
eliminate either one of those pretty
sure there's certainly a radial one cuz
that's centripetal there's got to be
some of that but might there be some in
the other direction okay so an
improvement on this a necessary
improvement I think is that rather than
just one we'd better have two and we're
gonna use my system of naming so that
the answers I've got here will work out
I call that one F 1 F 2 and this one F 1
so now the rod is placing on the cart
two reaction forces which you don't know
now is that the complete thing for the
cart okay now let's do this one
another group tell me how to do the
second one free body diagram
good point got an f2 this way and f1
like that is what you're saying okay an
mg yeah m2 G okay good real important
point you know Newton's third law if you
draw f1 f2 here those on that side have
to be equal equal and opposite you know
ready for all this to work out without
problems okay
those looks pretty good to me now let's
move on this is a complicated problem in
to get a lot a lot done with it in an
hour as a challenge and you've done a
bunch of this problem already you did
the one with the particle on it so it's
not a great deal of difference here but
I'm so I'm emphasizing a few of the
nuances what I now want to do is how to
is to talk about how do we get equations
of motion for this problem how many will
there be to start with gotta get to two
rigid bodies and two degrees and for two
degrees of freedom and you're going to
end up it's the two degrees of freedom
that's how you're gonna get two
equations of motion at the end okay
how many and I wrote written three up
there but it's not necessarily true well
you've been taught to this point two
different methods for getting at these
equations of motion can you describe
somebody to describe one for me how
would you how would you how would you
personally go about this problem
just pick a method and in words describe
it think of what you did in the last one
so if some of external forces is okay so
you on method one here I'll call it so
the summit you're gonna say some of the
forces on what so get two bodies here
right so stick one all right this on em
one for sure that one is translating and
it's you're gonna get an equation that
involves its X double dot right it's got
to be able to move back and forth you're
going to need an equation like this so
the sum of the external forces on that
mass has got to be equal to m1 times all
right and we can write an equation for
that in terms of this Freebody diagram
in that X in the I direction you've got
this you've got this you have the normal
forces and gravity don't contribute and
components of this and this have to be
added in right you have to do an F -
probably cosine theta and an f1 sine
theta and add them in because they're
the external forces so you get all these
summation of forces on that side that
gives you one equation this is this will
give you an equation for the motion of
the first mass and it'll have some
unknowns in it and what are they
just describe them so you're gonna get a
function over here of a couple unknowns
this end up going to be a function of
what that you don't know f1 and f2 and
the others and then also of X double dot
and theta and theta dots and so forth
you know all the variables in the
problem it these are two unknowns you
got to ultimately get rid of okay what
else are you going to do in method one
you got to deal with the second the
second mass right what would you do then
so some of the forces is now on m2 for
sure that's gonna give you a couple
equations what else could do you do in
your method
so it talks about what have I named him
I look at in that diagram there so so
you're going to do your torques about
some of the torques about a okay and if
you sum torques about a what are they
thank you guys let's just you pursue
that a little bit figure out what are
the torques about this point in this
problem okay what do you get some of the
torques about a
zees in which which positive Z X Y
positive Z coming out of the board what
produces torque about this point in this
problem just what just gravity and is it
positive or negative
and it's which is a component of gravity
perpendicular to this so it's probably
sine theta m2 G sine theta and the - so
it's minus m2g sine L over 2 you need
the moment arm sine theta in the K hat
direction right and that's going to be
equal to the angular dhdt about a right
some of the torques time rate of change
of the angular momentum about a cuz
that's what you've chosen to work about
and you know always have this term you
have to check okay so this that's the
method this is method 1 this is tau I'll
follow it out the Tau with respect to a
method you have to write this equation
you have two unknowns that pop up in it
you go to the second mass you write the
F equals MA for that and you're going to
get two equations if you do it in the
local coordinate system and the rotating
one mass times acceleration in the I
direction you get F one and a component
of gravity and in the J direction
M two acceleration J you get F two and a
piece that's acceleration of gravity you
you don't know this yet but you can find
it you know you know how to make that
you know how to find those velocities
now you've done it before so the
velocity of G with respect to O probably
going to have an X double dot I hat plus
something that'll be like an L over 2
theta dot and n wonder
hmm it's rotating like this J hat right
little J so there's your velocity you
could take the time derivative of that
to get an acceleration your next double
dot that's not true down here you get X
double dot and this one you get two
terms because that's a rotating piece
you get a centripetal term and an Euler
in term they come out of that so and
then now you know velocities and
accelerations you can put the
accelerations on this side you can solve
this first equation for F one second
equation for F 2 you take those and you
put them in here
and you finally have one of your
equations of motion down here the
external torque only involves gravity so
they're your f1 and f2 appear you have
to mess with those in this final
equation or not this is the reason you
use point a this equation does not
involve f1 or f2
there's no moments created by f1 and f2
the stuff on the right hand side is only
kinematics and mass moments of inertia
all right this thing will give you an i
with respect you can think of this as a
it's going to be give you an i with
respect to G theta double dot plus some
other terms and does that I want to talk
about this is this term go to zero is a
does velocity of a zero on this problem
no way and in what direction is it
horizontal right capital I hat P the
momentum of the second thing has these
velocity components it's M if the P is
equal to M times that and you have
velocity components in the I which is
the same as VA but you have a different
another velocity components not the same
so is that cross product going to be
zero no way you have to deal with that
term it happens that this you know you
can express a
with respect to a as H with respect to G
Plus our G a cross P and you know P
because you just found the MV and our
our G a is just L over 2 J little J all
right there just from here to here L
over 2 little no I excuse me
so that's our L over 2 I so you can you
can crank out this cross product then
you have to take the time derivative of
this right here this whole thing every
time when you take the time derivative
of this part you will get a piece you
get multiple pieces but one of them will
be minus that this thing creates a piece
that's exactly - that and they'll cancel
but you got to go through the cranking
it out till you get to that point
okay let's talk that's one method of
doing it let's talk briefly about a
second method what is the other way to
go about doing this problem
yes method 3 no we're gonna be hurry so
I can get to it
what would you a second way to do this
problem close relative but the first way
but I want you to have all these
different ways of doing it in your
toolkit because some problems are easy
more easily done there's another way
that this that is a this is perfectly
appropriate for this type of problem if
the problem that we were doing involved
this would you do this method what would
you do no can't use energy left
yeah that's next week right so the
second method is basically this is the
same this piece but the second part down
and this is the same sum of the forces
about m2 you do both of those forces you
do some forces for sure m1 and m2 but
the third step is you do sum of torques
about G you some torques about G which
is here what appear what are what
appears into some torques this mg
contribute no what are the external
torques about G
f2l over to positive f2l over to k so
that equation will give you something
torques about G will give you an F - L /
- okay and now you've got that done
known popping up in your torque equation
and you know that it also pops up in
these two equations because if we solve
them so now which way is why does this
one have a slight advantage over the MIS
method slight advantage over this method
well you don't get the F 2 or F 1
popping up in your torque equation you
immediately get to the answer for that
one so it's a little more efficient okay
so is there a way to get directly at the
two equations where after the second
equation is we get from this torque
thing the first equation we get from
resolving this this is a mass times X 1
double dot X double dot and you get this
function of F 1 and F 2 and you have to
substitute in for these F ones and F 2 s
they finally get that equation so that
takes us kind of tedious so how is there
a way to do get directly at this without
having to mess with F 1 and F 2 at all
and that's that's what is the key to
what you're talking about
let's look at something here let's do
the sum the vector sum of the forces on
M 1 we get an F let's look at our free
body diagram F 2 J plus F 1 I minus K X
minus BX dot and a minus m1g
well those are well we'll put them in
there just throw them in there this is
in my capital J plus N 1 plus n 2
capital J out here right is that all the
forces all the vector forces in that
problem I miss anything it's spring the
dashpot the forces caused by the rod
gravity and the normal forces okay and
we could figure out the component of
this to some of the forces on m1 in the
capital X direction we can figure that
out from this has components in that
direction you know from it's just of all
status these go away then you don't have
to deal with this stuff in the X
equation but there's our sum of the
forces on the first body let's do the
sum of the forces on the second body
what are they
okay so you got a minus m2g on it right
and what else
but with office sign right yep - Little
J minus f1 little eye and anything else
nothing right let's add the two together
so if we do at all then this is this one
has got to be equal to the mass m1 times
acceleration the X component I plus m1
acceleration in the I can't right over
here in the a Y in the J capital J hat
direction alright though so that gives
us mass times acceleration is what all
the sums of the forces is equal to same
thing here this is equal to the little
mass m2 times its acceleration and it'll
have components in the this is mass two
and it'll have components in the we can
put in the I hat direction and plus m2
acceleration to running it I'll do it
like this a to Y and this is in the J
direction and we now we go to things we
can add them together right and so if I
add them together and I put m1 plus m2
times Z its I'll just call it the total
acceleration well I don't want to do
that I want to say this
I'm hurrying kid we're running out of
time m1 times its acceleration becomes
m2 plus its acceleration is equal to and
now we sum up everything on the right
hand side and the key thing that happens
here is what happens at f1 and f2 it
completely drop out okay so on the right
hand side there is it's not a function
of f1 and f2 the equation of motion that
we were trying to get here was just in
the I direction that's all we need for
that big cart so if we go down here and
extract the I component of this total
sum
it'll be an equation it evolved m1 and
m2 and it involve you'll have cosines
and sines and Thetas and things like
that but no F ones no f 2s you will get
directly to this the final result that
you got here where you had to go in and
substitute in for F ones and f2 it'll
get it to you directly what do you need
to solve it though you need to know the
acceleration of mass 1 you know that
that's trivial you need to know the
acceleration of mass 2 and that you have
that that if you did by taking the time
derivatives of these terms you know the
acceleration of that mass so you need
that expression and you plug that in
here and everything on everything else
on the right hand side you know it's KX
dot B X dot minus mg and 1 g minus m2g
and so forth all the rest of stuff is
known yeah
well it gives you two questions one in
the one what at this point you would
break this into capital I and capital J
the one in the capital J Direction is
equal to zero there's no motion in that
direction for the main mass the cart
there's only motion in the in the
inertial frame X direction so that's all
you'll you could yet you have this is a
vector equation it has two pieces to it
I and J the J is a statics equation the
AI is your dynamic one and it's this one
that you would have found in in this
problem but without ever having to solve
for f1 and f2 but you do have to go out
and solve for do you have to find the
acceleration of both masses mass times
the acceleration what this is really
saying is this the way you asked about
the system this is sort of the system
approach if you think this whole thing
as a system draw a box around it the sum
of the external forces on the system is
equal to the mass the total mass times
actually the acceleration of the center
of mass of the system right but this
acceleration times the center of mass of
the system you can break this into two
pieces it is this term Plus this term
and then you you just that's the total
system and you add you sub all we have
to put on this side is the summation of
the external forces that the external
forces are not the internal forces don't
count they're not part of the system so
you only have to put the external forces
on it mg's springs dashpots normal
forces outside forces the only ones that
go over here reason we don't usually
think of doing this is because when you
think about the system you write it as
the acceleration of the center of mass
but you have to realize that you can get
that expression as
the sum of the parts the sum of each bit
times its acceleration and some of them
all up is the same answer as all the sum
of the masses times the acceleration of
the center of mass of the whole system
okay so all we still get it a couple of
minutes last hour I ran over and we
couldn't get to this so there isn't a
way there's a there's a yet another
thing you can do and that's think of the
thing as a whole system and sometimes
that'll give you an equation without
having to use F without having to solve
for internal forces pretty cool okay all
right so questions thoughts yeah
well I can't generalize on that I
haven't done enough problems like that
myself to even that to have a enough
experience you know just how often is
that going to help you out this one
there's a pretty obvious equation that
you're going to write in this direction
on that mass it's constrained to a
single motion and a single coordinate
you're assigning to it and probably in
cases like that where you can isolate
one of the rigid bodies you know it
might there might be some advantage in
doing something like this yeah I mean
this one it all of these methods all of
the message you're going to end up
having to compute the Excel velocities
and accelerations of each piece and if
you got that information you may as well
use it if there's something to be gained
by doing it something you know taking it
doing a clever step like this yeah so
this one this method 3 this is a this
shows you a different way to get that
equation just you still need this oh you
only this is clever way to get just this
first equation down you still need a
second equation and you still are going
to have to and then if you don't want to
have to mess with f1 and f2 so we've
just found a way to never have to mess
with f1 and f2 at least this problem and
that is get the first equation by using
this trick the system equation and it's
a sum forces
expression and then you use the second
equation you need is this moment
equation you have two choices about G or
about a and which one can you do it
without having to find f1 and f2 I'm
doing it about a ok so there's a way
that you can do this whole problem and
never have to address what f1 and f2 are
and that's kind of a combination of
two pieces here the traditional way the
textbook way you open it up textbook
will teach you this one and it'll teach
you about a and teach you about G but
you don't you often run into this
there's sometimes a direct way of
getting to one of the direct way of
doing it without finding the f1 and f2
unfortunately there are thousands of
problems in the world and you can't
start a little hard to say which in
advance what method to use and what's
going to work the easiest but these
there's some insights there are some
generalizations that you can get from
looking at things in these different
ways if you have forces at a pivot point
taking the moments at the pivot point
you know unknowns at the pivot point
taking the moments about that point will
get rid of them for you that's a one
generalization that you can usually take
to the bank but beyond that and if the
things unconstrained so if there's no
fix if it's fixed axis rotation then you
want to use about the axis of fixed axis
these are missing moving axis but it is
still rotating about it will fix a point
that's moving there's still some
advantage in doing this all right if
it's the the eraser problem this thing
where you have no fixed points of
rotation and if you take a body and you
you know do this with it where is it
spinning about where is its axis of
rotation always right that you can take
to the dam if there's no no forced pivot
bodies on their own only rotate about
their centers of gravity centers of mass
and then you when you have free bodies
that are not don't have constraints that
are forcing them to move with respect to
something if there's no constraints then
you want to take the torques about G for
sure
good alright see you guys next Tuesday